-Now, we all love
our pets, right?
And every pet owner
thinks their pet is the best.
-Homer!
-Well -- Homer, yes.
Shout-out to Homer.
Well, I wanted to see
if that was true,
so it's time for "Why Is
Your Pet Better Than Me?"
-♪ Why Is Your Pet
Better Than Me?♪
♪ Better Than Me♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
Let's meet our first pet.
Hello. What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name's Teresa Hanula,
and this is Leonard,
and we're from
Fairfax, Virginia.
-Hi, Teresa. Hi, Leonard.
Teresa, tell me about your dog.
Tell me about Leonard.
-Well, Leonard
is a 3-year-old Border Collie
who loves to learn new tricks,
and one of his favorite tricks
is to paint.
-To paint? Wow!
-Paint.
-So, I'm already --
I'm already guessing, yeah,
this is why your pet
is better than me.
Your dog paints?
-He paints,
and even though he's a dog
and he's just 3,
he's probably done
about 100 of his own
abstract paintings.
-Oh, my gosh.
All right. Leonard.
Can we see what Leonard doe--
Sorry to bore you, Leonard.
Uh, can we see
what Leonard does?
-Ready? Take. Good!
Now go paint it!
Good! There you go. Paint it.
-Wow.
-Yes! Wait.
Gonna put it...
Oh. Hey. Go paint it.
Yes. Go paint it. Yeah!
-Leonard, this is --
-Now go clean up.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Good boy!
-You impressed us, Leonard.
-Yeah! Good!
-Well, he's got --
he's got one more color.
Yeah, go for it. Yeah, Leonard,
let's see another color.
You want to do another one
-Good boy, Leonard! Good!
-There you go.
That's right, Leonard.
Yes. That's right.
That's a good boy.
-Good!
-Now he's done. He's done.
-Leonard!
-It's a masterpiece, Leonard!
Oh, my gosh.
That is what I'm talking about.
Leonard. Oh, my gosh.
He's so talented.
Thank you so much.
We're going to let Leonard
keep working.
We're going to check in with him
later to see how he's doing
with his painting.
Let's see our next pet
over here.
Hey. What's your name
and where you from?
-Hi. I'm Jeff Dalebout.
And these are my daughters,
Haley and Kelsey,
and we're from Provo, Utah.
-Haley. Kelsey. Hi!
Hi, Haley. Hi, Kelsey.
Welcome, guys.
And who do you have there
with you?
-This is Kittywinski.
He's a one-year-old male Tabby.
-Kitty -- Kittywinski.
-Yes.
-Very good.
Now, you said that
so matter of factly
like that's a common name.
You go, "Yes, of course.
Yes, of course. Kittywinski."
Tell me -- Can you tell me
why is your pet better than me?
[ Cat meows ]
-Kittywinski's a composer, and
he plays all of his own music.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
Let's -- Let's -- Let's see it.
Let's be real quiet
and let's hear Kittywinski.
Here we go.
-Can you play? Can you play?
Kittywinski, play.
Can you play?
[ Two piano notes play ]
Kittywinski, play.
Play.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That was a short song there,
but, hey, you know, he's back.
Kittywinski. Good job.
Thank you very much.
That was two notes on --
All right.
Let's meet our last pet here.
Welcome. What is your name
and where are you from?
-Hello.
My name's Holly Ashbrook.
And I'm from
Manchester, England.
-Manchester!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! I'm so happy you are here.
Please tell us a little bit
about your pets.
-Okay, so,
this girl here is Yuki,
and she's a Japanese Spitz.
And this little boy here is Ted,
and he is a Jack Russell
cross Miniature Pinscher.
-[ Laughs ]
They're very cute.
Can you tell me, why are
your pets better than me?
-Well, Jimmy, I believe
my pets are better than you
because they can dance
when I sing.
-They dance when you sing.
All right.
That sounds amazing.
I'm ready to see this.
Let's see this.
-Okay. Yuki, come here.
♪ If you're happy and
you know it, do a spin ♪
♪ If you're happy
and you know it ♪
♪ And you really
want to show it ♪
♪ If you're happy and
you know it, do a spin ♪
-There you go. That's not bad.
Oh, they give a high five?
[ Laughs ] Come on.
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
That is fantastic. Thank you!
Let's check back in with Leonard
and see how Leonard's doing.
Leonard. Oh, my gosh.
Leonard. Oh, my goodness.
That's unbelievable. That is --
I want to thank
all of our talented pets,
Leonard, Kittywinski,
Ted and Yuki.
If you have a pet that
you think is better than me
and want to see, go to...
to submit a video of your pet.